Mark Twain said something very beautiful
he said there are two most important
days in our lives first is the day when
we were born and second is the day when
we find out why the day we are born is
known to us the day when we find out why
is the day when we probably start
discovering our purpose and I remember
meeting the priest there and the priest
there told me an incredible story of the
St Paul's Cathedral when it was being
made the architect there probably about
1700s when he was making this Cathedral
one day he was not known to the people
who are working at the construction
inside one day the architect just walked
around and was just moving around to see
what was happening and he saw a brick
layer laying bricks he asked the brick
layer what are you doing the man replied
well I'm laying bricks he moved a little
ahead he saw another brick layer he said
what are you doing I'm laying bricks
because I need to make money for my
family he moved a little further ahead
and he saw another third brick ler he
said what are you doing he said I've
heard that this gentleman this architect
is creating a spectacular Cathedral and
I'm trying to lay the brick in such a
way that I can help him in making this
Cathedral extremely beautiful now you
really don't change what you do we don't
change what we do we have our jobs we
have our families it's easy to make a
bar it's hard to make a difference and
the core of purpose is how do we make a
difference in whatever it is that we do
and leave a legacy behind of trying and
adding value to the world that we live
in need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's EV car Michael
and I make these videos because as a
young entrepreneur I struggle to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories motivation today so today listen
from one of the best Guru gal Das and my
take on his top 10 rules for Success
enjoy rule number two is have patience
we live live in a world today
where everything's very quick to form
and everything's very quick to
break we live in a world of instant
gratification yeah we live in a world
where we don't have patients to stand in
a queue to buy something because we just
order it online yeah we live in a world
where I can't wait for a coffee to get
ready because I can go and put it in a
slot machine and get a cup of
coffee there's no
patience and it's not it's not an issue
with youngsters or older people it's a
generational
issue it's a issue technology has added
so much value to our lives but it's also
taken away things from us a virtue is a
part of you and it applies to every
aspect of your life a virtue is agnostic
it applies to any aspect of your life
positive negative both you know so I see
a lot of times that things like it's
like love at first sight and divorce at
first fight
break up at first
fight finished before marriage it's like
roses are red and the sky is blue you're
my sweetheart I love you kind of stuff
and after a while its roses are dead and
I'm blue you're my headache I'll kill
you you can
imagine there's no you know patience to
work on it when you when you when you
grow a plant when you grow a plant it
takes patience to sew the seed you have
to nurture it you to use the right kind
of fertilizers it water it before it
starts bearing fruits or flowers a
relationship is like a plant can't
expect it to happen overnight can't
expect it to happen in 6 months or 8
months or 10 months it's a journey and
it takes a while for a bonding to form
it takes a while for that respect to
develop the connection of your soul your
soulmate is not about some physical
stuff physical stuff is a consequence of
that being a soulmate it's not the
purpose of being a soulmate yeah but
over a period of time believe me you the
heart starts yearning for companionship
rule number three is stop people
pleasing I am someone who gets very
affected by what people think about me
or what people talk about me though I
know that you know none of that should
be considered at certain point time it
happens so that you know you start
getting affected and that you know that
result is affected because of that right
so how how do we deal with that yeah
it's a big problem for a lot of people
of how what other people think about me
uh so what happens with that kind of a
thought process is we become people
Pleasers and in being people pleases we
lose ourselves because I don't want to
do it but I'm doing it just because that
person should be pleased just because he
or she should think right about about me
we are a generation of people pleases
you know why because we survive thrive
and sustain on
validation what's social
media social media everybody on social
media simply living thriving surviving
and sustaining on validation one post
gets few likes your worth is not gone
man it's all right you more worthy than
the likes you get rule number four is
develop curiosity I feel over a period
of time to me there are four things that
really
distinguish a good leader from others
and the first
thing is the
Curiosity to always know and
learn the humility and the vulnerability
to say that I don't
know a lot of times the blind spot of
having achieved a certain amount of
knowledge is to think that I've cracked
it and I know it Innovation creativity
growth comes from
Curiosity and the vulnerability and
humility to say that well this is what I
don't know growth comes from not this
line that I know growth comes from I
don't know which means I have the
Curiosity to learn also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is control your
mind many of us are fascinated by cars
their speed their features their look
and feel their comfort their mileage and
even the stateus value if you're in the
passenger seat of a car we can do
whatever we like look at the side of the
road browse through our social media
feeds chat with someone on our phones
watch a movie or play a game or even go
to
sleep imagine the driver doing that
being distracted not being focused
paying attention to other things there
are high chances that we probably end up
meeting with an
accident even in life if we are in the
passenger seat we can easily get
distracted by our problems and
challenges or by our thoughts and
emotions if we want to remain focused if
you want to be peaceful and happy you
want to reach our destination our go we
have to take the driver's seat rule
number six is listen to your inner voice
this is the noise
around the noise around is get a job
have a startup
make
money get married have
children pretty much what life is for
everybody out there in the world right
that's the
noise and a lot of times I feel in that
noise somewhere we forget to listen to
our own voice some people in order to
follow their dreams they stare away from
the people whom they
love and some people in order to be with
the people whom they love they forget
their dreams and there in no wi so as I
was studying preparing for my exams
looking at the grades looking at what
could be the career options for the
future there was one thing that was
definitely
happening that one that that aspect of
me saying that well I don't want to
necessarily give into the noise that was
brewing that was brewing that was that
was changing with it I don't necessarily
want to belong to that noise and listen
to that
yeah uh and that's probably why then
this decision came that I don't want to
necessarily conform I don't want to be
just a part of the noise and I'm not
against what people say getting married
is perfectly fine having children is
perfectly fine building a nice house is
perfectly fine having a fantastic
well-paying job with a thick thick fat
paycheck is perfectly fine if that's not
me if that's not my
voice I felt hey I'm not going to do
this right W I'm not going to do this
was revolutionary it was Radical yeah it
was taking The Road Less Traveled not
traveled shall I not even less traveled
shall I say not traveled
practically uh taking a big time risk
yeah uh but yes I followed my heart I
followed that voice rule number seven is
practice self-control how uh important
self-control is in alive so basically
when I see you there's a lot of food
besides you and you are only eating Dal
rice when we edit videos in our CI Tales
office and we see a lot of good food and
we also feel like crave for eating food
so do you feel like you know craving for
things uh number one to be honest God
has been kind in the last couple of
years I've practically gone everywhere
seen everything eaten every possible
thing that could have you know been
available uh strangely as a monk
it's very strange that a monk gets to do
all of this stuff but I've gotten to do
all of that so there's a point in time
when you kind of say I've seen it all
done at all kind of stuff so then you
naturally come to stage of okay bus but
also through my having said that 26
years I've been taught a life of control
in my monk Life as a monk uh for the
first couple of years I was not couple
of years probably about more than a
decade I could only eat what was cooked
in the community kitchen if I like it I
don't like it doesn't or whatever meal
is cooked I would eat that right now do
I have cravings yes I do I'm a human
being I a human being right I have my
cheat days of course I I work out I work
out heavy but I have my cheat days too
last four five days I've been too much
cheating
but but I have my cheat days too not
that I don't not at all I'll tell you
how it is if we are at the race course
right just right behind behind of the
race course when you ride a
horse if you let the Ring of the horse a
little too
loose the horse goes Haywire runs helter
skilter all over the place if you
tighten the Ring of the horse a little
too tight you'll see the horse makes
screechy sound and comes up on its two
two
legs now too tight problem too loose
problem that's how the mind and the
senses are rule number eight is always
keep learning the reality is techn ology
has added value the reality is with the
brightest minds and with the brightest
opportunities and the brightest avenues
that have opened up technolog is
escalating to the next
level the reality of the matter is also
this that when technology comes up
there as aush rightly said it kind of
becomes a
threat to human existence to human
potential to the development of human
potential I was in Singapore one year
for an event called masters of the
century one of the keynote speakers and
I came up on stage I I did my bit I love
cracking jokes cracking people up
there's about 2,000 people in the
audience not a single Indian face I mean
you don't have a single Indian face
that's when you test your grounds
because when there's Indians they can
immediately connect I'm an Indian you
can really frequencies match but there I
was looking at people they enjoyed it
they gave me a standing ovation and I
went back stage and when I went
backstage everybody started shouting
Sophia Sophia Sophia
Sophia and I said these guys got it
wrong like and if you if you want an
encore they should have shouted gor
gopal gor gopal I said this gu have
gotten it wrong once I did an event and
people did shout because they wanted me
to be up on stage again go Goa sopia
Sophia I turned to my secretary I said
who the heck is the
sopia so this one guy come up comes up
to me and says would you like to meet
Sophia
sir I S oh oh I don't mind actually
considering the kind of enthusiasm from
the audience looks like Sophia must be
as someone and I thought in my mind it
was probably Sophia Vergara for Modern
Family so they said we'll take you to
see her so I I was walking towards the
The Green Room where Sophia was in my
mind and thinking of any possible
reference from Modern Family so that
when I meet Sophia Vergara I say ma'am I
saw this and it was a real life nine
good to connect on something that is
common as I came to the Green Room there
was two
huge bouncers their muscles were
Rippling out of their coats like real
out there they were standing there I
said this guy said I I'd like to see
Sophia sorry Sophia is getting plugged
in I said Sophia is getting plugged in
seemed like a new slang seemed like a
new slang Singaporean slang what's
plugged in or zoned in so I thought
plugged in would mean like you know
speakers like to get plugged into the
Ambiance the atmosphere just be in their
space and I was thinking like this maybe
she's doing makeup maybe she's doing div
some makeup some using some device to
plug in and soon after the doors opened
and there were two guys who were
carrying the first ever humanoid that
was made on planet Earth who was called
Sophia and when they say she's getting
plugged in means literally getting
plugged in and getting
charged Sophia came up on stage i s sat
in the audience to listen to what Sophia
said and they asked her a very
touchy sensitive question the funny part
is the answer was programmed in
Sophia they asked her do you think
artificial
intelligence and the technology that has
come up today will replace human beings
the question that aush has asked me I
cannot
forget what Sophie had answered in fact
my second book energize your mind begins
with the story right the story of
Sophia and I can't forget what Sophia
said Sophia
said it needs a human being to create a
Sophia and therefore there's no question
ever
that a Sophia can replace a human being
because without a human being a Sophia
cannot function you need an answer to be
programmed into a
machine and even with the growth of some
of these artificial engines with no
names the day before yesterday I typed
in to one of them and you know what I
mean no names you know what I mean I
typed in to figure out the details of
one of my friends who is a massive
businessman his son who's now leading
the business to check details guess what
guys he's just about 34 years
old this particular AI engine said that
he was dead in
1944 was dead in
1944 it requires a sensient human being
true to run technology to create
technology and that's why Sophia I
remember
said I'm not here to compete with human
beings I'm here to complement
human beings and what human beings do
and what human beings do to complement
what human beings do it's our human
responsibility to while we use all
technology to while we upgrade to the
best that is
available to not do away with the human
potential that is behind it rule number
nine is do what makes you happy if you
understood life right you would know
that when you grow up you want to be
happy yeah and I feel when you are happy
doing what you do is when you make the
most impact correct if I'm a
motivational speaker and not happy being
a motivational speaker what am I giving
to the world a product not not my joy
not what I truly feel or not the real
not the real authentic self so if I'm
authentic it makes a tremendous impact
yeah in what I do so of course it comes
with time I can't can't say that when I
was growing up I felt that I'm going to
make a difference I'm going to be my
genuine self and AU S I took to the
beaten path of being an engineer but
then with time they realized that this
is not me I can't fit and I can't just
conform I can't just comply with
whatever is just existing I need to find
my voice and not drown myself in the
noise that's going on all around us in
society and R number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
Celebrate life I really want you to help
us with one life advice that we all
should follow in 20 23 along with the
celebration I think we should also have
some deliberation okay and the
deliberation should be on what went
right in the last year whatever went
right can we bring it to this year and
also build upon it deliberation on what
went wrong in the last year can we even
correct it a little bit and improvise it
Rectify it a little bit because not
let's not just make parties events
social functions as celebrations let's
make life as a celebration yeah and if
you want to make life a celebration in
2023 I think we should look at what went
right bring it back into 2023 what went
wrong Rectify a little bit of that in
2023 and we should always remember that
in the book of our life yeah uh many
chapters of our book are written already
and the last chapter of whatever your
age is today yeah 31st of December this
year that that chapter will be closed as
well right you can't do anything about
it but beginning 1 of January the new
chapter that year is completely blank
don't feel too much remorse don't feel
too much guilt don't liit that trap that
I'm I didn't do it I couldn't do it I'm
a failure let's begin aesh with Zeal
with enthusiasm with tremendous Hope and
Faith and confidence that I can do it I
will do it I will take support and help
whenever need it but I'll get where I
want to
be
we all have that villain in our life
right or so we call
them cuz sometimes it's a perception
that they villain sometimes the reality
that they villains we all have that
person in us in our stories we all have
that one person in our
[Music]
stor just to purify you of all of this
sent you that every everybody has that
one person in their lives just one
taster that I want to give you just one
thing so much can be said on that topic
like I it's a whole discussion in
itself but when you forgive
someone that's not necessarily for
them when you forgive someone that is
for
you for your
peace so that you come to peace with
things
sometimes what they do doesn't even
deserve
forgiveness you know what I say often
forgive or not forgive is a very
individual
choice if you want to live in peace
however it is imperative that we let go
of what we have held in our mind and we
pent up in our
minds because small or less this phone
may be what 200 g 300 G if I hold this
phone on my palm
it's going to hurt me a little bit for a
while if I hold it for 2 hours it's
going to hurt my wrist a lot if I hold
it for an entire day it's going to start
numbing my if I hold it for an entire
week without putting it down it's going
to paralyze my
wrist it's not what you hold and how
long you hold it's not what you hold and
how heavy it is but how long we hold it
so to keep down that
phone is some compassion to my own
wrist not to the
phone so what I hold for somebody is
like that phone it's not so much for
them it's for my own peace it's for my
own my own coming to terms with my own
Joy you
know and and forgiveness doesn't
necessarily mean forgetting
it we've always been told forgive and
forget forgive and forget forgive and
forget no you know what when we are
talking about about forgiving and
forgetting forgiving is about stopping
that person that person's actions that
person what that person's doing to
influence how we feel
now memories are not going to be easily
erased memories of what people have done
to us do you think memories can be
easily
[Music]
erased you know what when I take a am I
okay to take a picture of you all of you
[Music]
guys Instagram
story see I'm going to take a
picture show you Qui leave here's a
picture
correct if I want to delete this
right it's gone and now if I go to my
trash in this and delete it it's
permanently deleted from the memory
correct but that's because this is a
phone any impression that is made on the
SIM card or on the memory of this phone
in Sanskrit is called a
samsar samsar means an impression that
is made on something it goes through
this lens and leaves an impression on
there
but these impressions are very easy to
delete at the Press of a delete button
is got from your
memories guess what ladies and
gentlemen in our life through what we
read hear what happens to us there a lot
of sscar happening on this memory
here and they are not
easy to
delete so I'm not even that's why I said
I'm not even asking you to delad them
you need to be so elevated spiritually
to be able to just go leave it all
behind we are not we are people living
in the real
world so when we say forgive we saying
don't allow that person Now to control
your
peace let
go but we are also simultaneously saying
that there is going to be that side and
every single time you see that
person imagine an abuser coming in front
of those person
used that
memory going to trigger everything back
again everything back again and that's
precisely why during the course of my
talk I had said forgiveness saying a
sorry doesn't happen we have to make it
happen by shifting our attention
elsewhere a I'll stay away from my
triggers which trigger that memory but
if that memory does come to me and I
feel
angry I feel hurt I feel everything
coming to me I'll be compassionate to my
own self and say it's
okay it's okay be compassionate to
yourselves compassion is not just meant
for
others so be
self-compassionate if you feel anger you
feel anger if you feel hurt you feel
hurt if you go through what you go
through you go through what you go
through don't stay there because it's
ruining your life I've done three talks
in three cities in B in
India early late morning like about 9ish
I've spoken in Bangalore in India after
that Z come to the airport go to Chennai
for another one finish that and come
back to Mumbai and straight from the
airport go to another I've done three
talk in three cities in a day what do
you if I snap well you're technically
right I did but you're practically wrong
ladies and gentlemen I don't snap like
that you can interact with me all the
time I don't snap like that but I'm a
human body and a human machine in your
relationships ladies and gentlemen I
make a humble appeal to all of you and
beg of you life is
short it's very
short don't mess up with people the
closest people to
you give time to
them and
understand
them they may be you they may have said
something here and there and you may be
technically right okay look at the
Hidden Mango yes your husband or your
wife may not love you and that's
technically
right but there may be a Hidden Mango
why find that out before you brand them
your son or daughter may not listen to
you and you may be completely
technically right that they don't obey
you but find out the Hidden Mango why
are they doing what they are doing they
are doing doing that is clear everybody
knows it it doesn't need two pin worth
of Common Sense is it a rocket science
to understand that is it a rocket s to
understand he's not behaving right any
damned fool can understand it it needs
intelligence and maturity to go behind
the technical rightness and look for the
Practical rightness it looks it needs
maturity and wisdom to start seeing
behind the scene to say why is this
person not loving me why is this person
behaving like like that why is this
person not treating me right and if you
do that believe me hand on my heart your
love for whoever you
love will go so deep and your
relationship with whoever you relate to
will be so profound because it's based
on maturity not judgmentalism it can be
fun to once in a while revisit your
childhood days and relive them one day I
happened to see a remote controlled
helicopter someone had and decided to
give it a try having lost practice of
using a joystick it was a little hard in
the beginning but in a few attempts I
thought I was becoming a pro in flying
it it was then that I remembered how a
friend of mine from London had taken me
for a ride on his private plane as we
were taking off I recollect sharing an
inspiring quote with my friends on that
flight I had said when everything seems
to be going against you remember that
the airplane takes off Against the Wind
not with it well the tiny cesna we were
flying in definitely gave us a real time
experience of that quote as it was super
wobbly during takeoff but we had a very
smooth Landing don't they say all is
well that ends well recently I decided
to try a real Adventure a one in which
you take off in a plane but don't land
in it
skydiving the night before I'm lying in
bed visualizing myself jumping off the
plane thinking what if the parachute
doesn't open what if it opens but
malfunctions when we are in the air What
if I have a free fall straight on the
ground ladies and gentlemen do you know
what's stopping us from taking the
plunge do you know what's stopping us
from growth toward words what if what if
I fail what if I lose what if people
mock me what if he or she says no what
if what if what if what if life will
pass away and our minds will stop us
from realizing our truest and fullest
potential that night I decided to
confront my what if and shut my mind up
I asked myself do you want the
experience of jumping off a
plane yes came the answer from
within then know what else whatever
happens be ready for it I said to my
mind to make sure it was not an
uncalculated risk I decided to evaluate
the risk factor when I checked the
statistics of skydiving casualties on
Google it was 13 fatalities in 3.3
million skydives last year way less than
the car accidents that took place last
year but what if I happen to be one
amongst the 13 my mind protested again
then lie down here in bed snoring and
being a couch potato missing the
accelerating experience in your life I
told my mind as I drifted away into
sleep crossing the crippling boundary of
wfs I remember telling
myself look darling your skydiving
support tomorrow is an expert
he has had several years of experience
with thousands of skydives and not a
single casualty was recall relax take it
easy the next day as the doors of the
plane opened at 18,000 ft above ground
level I was ready telling myself I want
to do it I can do it I will do it I
remember standing at the edge of the
plane door now fearlessly looking down
and then we
jumped that Free Fall was the most
liberating experience of my life
Liberation from the two paralyzing words
what if as we floated in the air feeling
light like never before the parachute
opened and I thought to myself today the
parachute is opened and so has my mind
open your minds face those things that
are holding you back cross the limiting
boundaries of your wfs believe me an
amazing life Waits ahead on the other
side of Wars Let's Get the facts right
success is not just about
achievements this's this narrative that
the more you have the more successful
you are but I know people who have a lot
and have serious mental health health
issues I consider that a
failure I know about we we we left we we
we just lost Mr raak junjun Wala and we
remember what he said remember his words
he said I have about $5 billion worth
and he said I only wish God Gave Me
Better Health if I have all the money in
the world and my mental health is at
stake my emotional health is at stake my
physical health is at stake my spiritual
health is at stake my social health is
at stake and my success
ful so let's not make one element of
success as success yes achievements and
financial success is a very crucial
element but not the element you know a
balance and having paid attention to all
of these aspects is when we can truly
call ourselves successful like one
gentleman asked someone you know uh what
is the difference between the word
complete and finished he said well if
you find a right partner in your life to
get married to your life is
complete if you get the wrong
one your life is
finished but if the right one catches
you with the wrong one in life is
completely
finished sorry about that sorry but I
think I think when we're looking at we
want to complete everything isn't it and
which is precisely why it's important we
complete our definition of success too
by including those elements that are
important for our life not just for our
lifestyle achievements in money is about
lifestyle emotional mental social
spiritual health is about our life and
lifestyle and life must go handin hand
that's when success is completed and if
you're looking at three elements which
we really must look at whatever aspect
of success if you want to be successful
number one is we shouldn't be goal
focused we should be process focused I
see a lot of guys go to the gym you know
uh uh any of you guys go to the gym
okay brilliant any of you want to reduce
your weight a little bit oh God my
God that guy needed a whack trust me you
know now when you go to a gym I see
these younger guys going to a gym and
doing bicep curl that's the only
exercise they
on because that's the way to girls show
your guns so you'll see them go to the
gym I'm going to put the microphone down
for a second even if you don't hear me
it's fine guys they'll do this and
they'll
swing the biceps don't lift the weight
at all it's the body that's lifting the
weight and in the mirror they're
saying they should be isolating their
biceps and just picking the weight with
the biceps right so when your goal
focused you don't get the goal when your
process focused you reach there so
whatever it is in your life that you
want to achieve focus on the process the
more consumed You Are by the process
this greater chances you reach the goal
then just focus on on the goal and not
on the process the one thing that I've
learned over the years is that we are
all so different our lives are so
different our situations are so
different our backgrounds are so
different our upbringing is so different
the Journey of our life up until now for
each one of us is so different compared
to somebody else and therefore it's so
important that we don't judge our own
life all the lives of others by
comparing them with someone else's life
here's an example if Mr a can Sprint a
distance of 10 km in 1 hour whereas Mr B
covers the same distance in 1 and a/
half hour which one of the two would you
call faster and healthier the answer
obviously would be Mr a now what if I
tell you that Mr a had a prepared track
to run on when Mr B dided by walking on
a Sandy path I think our answer will now
change and we probably think that Mr B
is fitter and let's say we come to know
that actually Mr a is 75 years old old
while B is only 20 here we go our answer
changes again and we now think that the
75y old Mr a is healthier guess what Mr
a weighs 60 kg whereas Mr B 125 kg which
makes it really hard for him to run who
do you think did well oh my goodness now
we correct ourselves again as we favor
Mr B the more we get to know about the
strengths and limitations of Mr A and B
respectively our opinions and judgments
about who is better keep changing and
isn't life like that as well guys we
form opinions about others so quickly so
hastily so impulsively so superficially
without knowing much about them or their
situations we end up judging people
labeling people and miss out on
connecting to and encouraging the
immense potential that they may have
life is not the same for all
some may not be as talented as others
but may get better opportunities and
thus scale up very fast whereas others
despite being super talented keep
struggling just to make the ends
meet some may have more resources
whereas others can't find any source to
fall back on each one has different
problems and so no one solution can work
for all just like one size of clothing
doesn't fit all so do not judge others
Journey without knowing more do not
judge your own life by looking at
someone else's or comparing your
situation with someone else's you are
you and they are they your life is your
life and theirs is theirs do take
inspiration from their journey in a way
that you can enrich yours and always
remember life is the most difficult exam
many people fail because they try to
copy others not realizing that everyone
has a
different question paper Israel has two
famous lakes the Dead Sea and the Sea of
Galilee the Dead Sea is a lake with very
high salt content as high as
35% which is almost 10 times the normal
ocean Ian water such a high level of
salinity not only means that a human
body can float on the surface of the
water but also that there is no life at
all in this Lake no fish no vegetation
no sea animals nothing lives in this
Lake and that's how it gets its name the
Dead Sea just to the north of the Dead
Sea is the Sea of Galilee yet completely
unlike the Dead Sea the Sea of Galilee
is pretty resplendant with abundant
colorful marine life lots of plants lots
of fish in fact the Sea of Galilee is
home to over 20 different types of
fishes and guess what both the lakes are
in the same region and both receive
water from the very same Source the
River Jordan yet while one is full of
life the other is dead the question
obviously is how how not sure how
technically correct this is but some say
the reason is because the River Jordan
flows into the Sea of Galilee and then
flows out the water simply passes
through the Sea of Galilee in and then
out and that keeps the lake healthy and
vibrant teeming with marine life but the
Dead Sea being far below the mean sea
level has no Outlet the water flows in
from the river Jordan but does not flow
out and since there are no Outlet
streams it is estimated that over a
million tons of water evaporate from the
Dead Sea every day leaving it salty and
too full of minerals and thus unfit for
any marine life isn't life very similar
like the two Lakes receive water from
the River Jordan we may also be
fortunate enough to to receive resources
knowledge love respect from others but
if we do not learn to share what we have
received we may end up like the Dead Sea
the love the respect the resources the
knowledge could all evaporate but if
like the Sea of Galilee we share what we
have we will be full of life and joy
ready to receive more and share more and
live in a space of abundance there are
five levels of
people on level one the lowest level is
a person who only sees bad in others For
Heaven's Sake that Gody just cannot see
any good anyone here like that I don't
think so we're not so bad that we just
can't see any good some people just
can't see any you know it's like when
you like someone even if the guy does
the biggest crime you say
Mar you like him but when you don't like
like someone even if he does the good
best thing you don't like him and if you
have that experience if you just don't
like someone even if he has all the good
qualities you just can't like
him there are some people on the lowest
level they only focus on the bad they
can't see the good a level higher are
those who see the good and the bad but
conveniently ignore the good and focus
on the bad
how often it happens when we live with
people there's so many good things in
them but conveniently we neglect the
good things and only focus on the bad my
husband digs the nose
[Music]
okay he digs his nose but he also does
many other good things how come you
forgot all of those and only water how
you only saw that how come you only saw
that you know we conveniently neglect
the good and focus on the bad bad the
third category of people are those who
see good and
bad equally and they're neutral they're
not concerned good bad they're in their
own
world the fourth category are those who
see the good and
bad they choose to ignore the bad or
deal with the
bad and focus on the good if you want to
like a person you have to be on level
four if you want to like a person if
you're on level two where you're
ignoring the good and focusing on the
bad how will you like that person and
how will that relationship be
deep when you're on level four where you
choose to ignore the bad or if the need
be deal with the bad and focus on the
good and the fifth level is those who
only see good that's God and SP
spiritually enlightened individuals who
will only see good in others anybody
here who's on level one only seeing bad
can raise your hand nobody okay thank
you anybody is here on level five only
seeing good if you raise your hands I
don't believe you oh sorry madam I do
believe you I'm I didn't see you raise
your hand I was just joking sorry I'm I
I truly believe you madam I I didn't see
you raise your hand please I just
happened to sa by thinking nobody is
thank you madam we really appreciate can
we give a loud Round of Applause for her
my God
amazing okay now in your close
relationships in your close
relationships how many of you find
yourself many times stuck at level
two level two where you kind of look at
the bad and forget the good that they
have thank
you in our relationships we need to come
to
level four one of my friends used to say
life is unfair get used to it how many
of you heard that one
yeah and there's another friend of mine
who's a big businessman he said life is
unfair learn to
[Music]
negotiate two contrary statements one is
saying life is unfair get used to it
like giving in and the other saying life
is unfair
negotiate work on something which one's
right which one's wrong both are
right life is
unfair learn to live with it when things
come and you can't change it acceptance
is the only way and life is unfair learn
to negotiate solve problems and craft
your own
[Music]
happiness I tell you
what that is life we all have the choice
to craft our
happiness make a happy life remember if
life gives you a
cactus you don't have to sit on
it you can do what you need to do with
the cactus but you can also learn to
choose to live a better life ladies and
gentlemen
life can get finished anytime before
life gets finished complete your life by
adding these values to your life secrets
of living well is what makes you have a
happy
[Music]
life one guy asked what is the
difference between the word complete and
finished the fellow said if you find the
right partner to get married to in your
life your life is
complete if you get the wrong one
life is finished but if the right one
catches you with the wrong one life is
completely finished
guys but before life is finished let's
complete it there was a king who had a
pack of 10 wild dogs he used them to
punish all those ministers who committed
blunders one day one of his ministers
made a mistake the king was Furious and
passed an order that the minister be
thrown to the dogs desperate to save his
life the minister pleaded your majesty I
Faithfully served you for 10 years and
in return is this what you would do to
me but if that's what you want fine you
may throw me to the dogs but before
doing so can you please do me a small
favor for 10 years of my service may I
request you to kindly grant me just 10
more days before the dogs tear me off to
Pieces the king agreed to The Minister's
proposal the minister then approached
the guard who was in charge of caring
for the dogs and requested that the
guard allow him to look after them for
the next 10 days unaware of the king's
order the guard was a little surprised
why would a minister want to do this
but being delighted that he would get a
break the god agreed the minister had
experience of caring for wild animals
from before he had joined the king and
so for the next 10 days he served the
dogs with great love and attention
feeding them bathing them cleaning for
them and making them feel very
comfortable after the 10 days were over
the king ordered that the minister be
now thrown to the the dogs when it was
done to the Kings and everyone else's
amazement the dogs started licking the
feet of the minister being baffled by
what was happening the king asked what
has happened to these dogs why don't
they attack and kill this Minister
before anyone could say a word the
minister instantly replied to the king
your highness I serve the dog only for
10 days and even in such a short term of
service they did not forget what I did
for them yet I served you for 10 years
and you very conveniently and easily
forgot all that I did for you just
because of one mistake that I made in
all these years the king felt ashamed of
himself and Having learned a vital
lesson in personal dealings ordered for
the minister to be freed and accepted
him back in his service isn't it a fact
that as soon as there is a provocation
or a mistake made or a troubling
situation that comes up we very quickly
forget all the good that others have or
the good that others have done for us
gratitude is firstly about a sharp
memory memory of all the kindness
service and good that we have received
it is then about action reciprocation
showing our goodness by letting go of
the one-off blunders that may happen and
to positively continue our relationship
with others let us not wipe off the good
that others have done unto us because of
small mistakes situations or incidents
how many of you breathe
I am sorry for asking that question how
many Of You' been breathing for the last
couple of minutes as I started this
talk I'm sure all of you have how many
of you are conscious of your
breathing mindful of your breathing I
don't think so any of us how many of you
use an Apple watch any of you here and
do you know that on an Apple Watch
there's a facility which gives you
giving you reminders after every 1 hour
time to
breathe
yeah if you use an Apple Watch you know
that it gives you a reminder after every
1 hour time to breathe and focus and
being mindful of your breathing ladies
and
gentlemen none of us in the last one odd
hour of shall I say through the day have
been conscious of our breathing now
imagine when you start breathing and you
just keep breathing in and then and then
and then and then can you live
no and imagine if you start breathing
out and you breathe out and you breathe
out and you breathe out can you
live no can you imagine how life is
fashioned in such an incredible
sophisticated refined
Rhythm the rhythm of
breathing when we talk about life we
talk about the rhythm of
breathing we're so unconsciously this
taking in and this giving out this
taking in and this giving out if we just
keep taking in we choke up and if we
just keep giving out we choke up what an
incredible balance life has to teach us
what an incredible Rhythm simply our
breathing has to teach us that life
can't just be a life of takers where we
just keep taking taking just taking or
taking nor can life be
just giving giving giving
giving the rhythm of breathing gives us
an incredible
[Music]
message take
in to give
out
have to
share grab to care that incredible
balance that
incredible equation is what makes life
amazing yoga is an incredible
science that helps us transform our
physical
fitness which is what it's largely known
for today but beyond even physical
fitness it's that science which can help
us enhance our mental
Wellness but I think even Beyond mental
Wellness yoga is a science that
facilitates the deepening of our
spiritual
awakening but to be honest
More Than Physical Fitness more than
mental Wellness More Than A Spiritual
Awakening yoga is a tradition a culture
a set of values a set of beliefs that
can truly help us deal with much larger
issues in the world than Fitness may it
be climate change or may it be issues
that are being tackled by the 17
sustainable development goals of the
United Nations poverty hunger gender
equality education life on land life
underwater whatever these sustainable
goals
maybe yoga has a
solution a proposed solution to deal
with these larger problems and
challenges that the entire world
confronts today I know that as soon as
we hear the word yoga as a solution for
Global issues we skeptical how can a
system of
exercise how can a system of
breathing be a solution to Global issues
and problems which is why I very
strongly and firmly believe that we have
to start thinking about yoga as more
than exercise we have to start thinking
about yoga as dimension
which has the tenants to offer us
solutions to our Global problems a man
during his travels once came up to a
mountain where he found a lady
meditating under a tree quite intrigued
by her presence in a solitary place like
this he asked her what are you doing
here alone in such a secluded place the
lady replied that she had a lot of work
to do on that mounted a little amused
the man asked a lot of work I cannot see
anything around you here what do you
have to do up here on this mountain the
lady replied well have to train two hogs
and two Eagles teach two rabbits
discipline one snake motivate a donkey
and tame a lion and if I might ask you
where are they I don't see any of them
up here question in the man actually sir
you'll never be able to see them because
they all live inside here within me said
the lady the Hawks stare at everything
that comes to me people good or bad
situations good or bad things good or
bad and I have to work hard to train
them to focus on the good side the Hawks
represent the vision behind my eyes
and the two eagles with their claws can
hurt and Destroy I have to train them
not to hurt those Eagles are my hands
that need to do something constructive
for the world and not create or engage
in anything hurtful or destructive
rabbits are very Swift and they want to
go wherever they want to go I have to
teach them to not just run around but
run in the right direction after all
what use is the speed if there is no
Direction the rabbits represent my feet
and I always want them to go in the
right direction in life the donkey is
often lethargic and at times acts very
stubborn I need to motivate it to
continue on with its work my mind is
exactly like the donkey it takes up
something but then loses the enthusiasm
to continue and also can be very
obstinate at times a lot of hard work
goes into dealing with this donkey sir
to plead with it to keep going on and on
the most difficult to tame however is
the snake although it is locked in a
strong cage with 32 bars it's always
ready to sting bite and poison anyone
nearby I have to discipline it and that
is my tongue I have one lion too oh how
proud how vain he thinks he's the king I
have to tame him and show him his real
position and that's my ego so now you
see my dear sir I have lots of work to
do up here on the mountain ladies and
gentlemen all of us have lots of work to
do as well internal work that can
transform our external life so let's
stop gossiping let's stop criticizing
let's stop evaluating and judging others
let's start looking at and working on
our own lives isn't it said yesterday I
was trying to be clever so I wanted to
change the world today I'm trying to be
wise so I know that I need to change
myself they say Pride comit
before the fall you can make things as
big you can be as successful as
ambitious but when there is
pride God
knows how to crush that Pride to powder
you know I mean I I have been a speaker
for years now and sometimes you know I
give talks and people are like sitting
and hearing and most time people come
and
say
this is what I gave the talk
for but there was one man one man came
up to me and said I said to me I hate
your
[Music]
lectures this is the first
time I hate your lectures so I asked him
you hate me he said so
I said look at this guy I was so
humbled I went to my college College of
Engineering Puna he was from there he
was one of the alumni so was I so there
was an alumni program I was invited as a
keynote speaker I went for the speech I
was all prepared for what to say all my
notes were there my mind was prepared my
words were there I had already
visualized myself standing at the dial
speaking how the students were all was
visualization was done so it wasn't it
was peanuts I've been doing it all my
life
I'll tell you
something that
day this guy was sitting at the back way
back in the program and he was standing
up and hearing my talk and just 2 3
weeks back he had told me I hate your
lectures I'll tell you it happened
several times but this time the Fiasco
that I did in my
lecture you cannot
imagine everything was here I knew
everything my lecture notes were all
there just couldn't speak spoke
something of course students didn't
detect after 15 18 years of
speaking but for me I knew I wasn't
together it was a big
failure when I came back it Puna on my
return in the car two students alumni
were with me talking to them what could
have been the reason for this mess up go
up many reasons but one reason was
Pride Pride you know it's no problem
doing big things ambitious things
successful Titanic
success but when there is pride that
success is a failure you know with pride
a success is a failure and with humility
an apparent failure is a success because
you can come out of that
failure because you made it this far in
a video I'm I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for 10 more amazing rules from sadguru
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there this unwinding
business has become very popular
everybody's talking about unwinding
detoxing and whatever first of all why
are you to so toxic and then you want to
detox yourself you eating wrong you're
thinking wrong